ELIAS PINTO: Oh,
hey there, Nick.
NICK PAN: Hey, Elias.
Fancy seeing you here.
ELIAS PINTO: I don't often
see you down these parts.
Now, where's that
old boat of yours?
NICK PAN: It's that
beaut over there.
The one with that
light blue spinnaker.
ELIAS PINTO: Spinnaker you say?
Now, what's that?
Is that one of those
whiz bang new gizmos
I should be knowing more about?
NICK PAN: A spinnaker?
And you call yourself a sailor?
You old buccaneer.
A spinnaker is the
front sail of your boat.
You know what else it is?
ELIAS PINTO: What?
NICK PAN: Spinnaker
is an open source,
multi-cloud, continuous
delivery platform
for releasing software
changes with high velocity
and confidence.
Let's jump to a demo.
So this is the
Spinnaker dashboard.
And on this dashboard, you're
able to see the resources
that Spinnaker manages.
In this case, we're managing
resources on Google Cloud
platform, and we're
actually going
to exhibit a demo, which
is a developer pushing code
into a release branch, having
that release branch be built,
tested, validated, and then
promoted into production,
and then deployed
into production.
So as we see here, we
have two load balancers--
an ingress load balancer
for a staging environment,
as well as an
ingress load balancer
for a production environment.
Both of these are hooked up
to Google Kubernetes engine
clusters, and you'll
see here they're
both wearing the
same Go application
with a white background
just exhibiting
the text "hello world."
So let's say I'm a developer
and want to release a feature
change to this application.
In this case, we're just going
to change the background color
from white to yellow, and
to do this I would just
jump to my source code.
I go ahead and adjust
the index at HTML
file to go from white to yellow,
or in this case, light yellow.
And then I would just push this
commit into my version control.
For this case, I'm using GitHub.
So we just go through the
standard get commands,
and we add a commit
to say that we're
adjusting to light yellow.
And then once we actually
push that into our codebase,
we're able to kick
off our CI/CD,
or Continuous Integration
Continuous Deployment,
pipeline.
So I'll just go ahead and log in
to GitHub, and then from here,
we'll kick off that process.
So if I hover back into the
actual Google Cloud Platform
console, you'll see here that
we have a tool known as Google
Cloud Source Repositories.
And what this tool
does is allows
you to mirror
GitHub repositories
within Google Cloud backed
by reliable, durable object
storage.
If you see here,
we've already noticed
that commit that I
pushed into GitHub,
and you'll see
that commit adjust
to light yellow background.
And here this is being
noticed almost in real time.
From here, we have
a container registry
build trigger that's
basically monitoring
that cloud repository and
building a container, which
will be our docker artifact
that will then deploy
into the Kubernetes cluster.
So you'll see here
there's a trigger that's
monitoring our GitHub repo.
So we have created
this docker image.
It's been built just now.
It's 288 megabytes in size, and
we've tagged it with two tags--
one, latest; and
the other one, MD5
hash digest of the commit ID.
So this is where
Spinnaker comes in.
What Spinnaker does is that
it monitors a docker registry,
and when there's
a new image that's
uploaded to that registry,
it'll kick off a pipeline.
So I hit the Refresh button.
We should see a pipeline
for deploying to stage
that's about to be run.
So you'll see here,
it's now running.
So at this stage, what it
does, if you see over here,
it's monitoring
that docker registry
or that Google
Container Registry
to see when an image is
actually uploaded there.
Once it detects an
image has been uploaded,
it then begins the
deployment process.
So here you can see
we're deploying it
to our staging environment
using a red/black deployment
strategy.
So this takes some
time to complete.
We're going to
take a quick break,
and I'll come back
once it's completed.
All right, and we're back.
You can see that that deployed
a stage step completed,
and now we're held up
at this validate stage.
What's awesome
about Spinnaker is
that it gives you the ability
to have a human intervention
in your pipeline.
So you have the
manual judgment step,
which allows you to
approve this pipeline
and move on to
the next step when
you've confirmed
that you're staging
environment looks good to go.
So I'll go back to
our cluster side.
We'll click on that ingress
load balancer, find that IP,
and I still have that
opened in my tab.
So I'll go to my top
right and check this page.
When I refresh
this, it does show
that we've made that
change, and it is now
a light yellow background.
If we looked at the
production environment,
we'll see that's still
showing a white background.
So we'll say this is good to go.
We'll hit Continue and now
basically go to the next step.
We have confirmed that we've
validated that the release
stage is good to
go, and now we're
at the point where we're
comfortable to promote
to production.
So in this promote to
production pipeline,
we have numerous steps.
And this also takes
some time to complete
but ensures we are able
to do a reliable as well
as a repeatable deployment.
So I'm going to pause the video.
We're going to come back
once it's completed.
And there we have it.
The promote to production
stage has completed.
At this point we should
have that pristine docker
image deployed into our
production Kubernetes
environment.
So we go back to that
ingress load balancer.
I still have that tab
open with that IP.
At the moment, it's
still showing white,
but when I hit Refresh, it
should go to light yellow.
There you go.
So at this point, we've done
an end-to-end CI/CD deployment
from source code
into build steps,
released into a
staging environment,
and then promoted
into production.
And Spinnaker is what
makes this all possible.
ELIAS PINTO: I thought
I knew everything
about sailing and GCP.
But boy, I was wrong.
If you're working
on cool projects
and you want to get
in touch with us,
click on the link
below to contact us.
Till next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]